it is great to welcome back to the
program today Andrew yang who is an
author and entrepreneur and notably most
recently running as a Democrat for
president in 2020 on a platform as we
discussed last time of universal basic
income Medicare for all and human
centered capitalism Andrew so great to
have you back on today thanks for having
me it's a pleasure to be here so you're
joining us from Iowa today an important
state in the primary presidential
primaries on both the Republican and
Democratic side we've seen since the
last time we spoke to you the field get
significantly more crowded on the
Democratic side with candidates of sort
of varying political ideologies within a
relatively narrow narrow spectrum um
what do you see as the primary way in
which you're different than all of those
other candidates right now you know um I
I think anyone who takes any time to
look at our platform sees that we are
quite different from other candidates
the main thing and as you suggested one
of the first pillars of our campaign is
the freedom dividend the universal basic
income of $1,000 per month which would
make an enormous difference in the lives
of tens of millions of Americans right
now 57% of Americans can't afford
unexpected $500 bill and putting $1,000
a month into their hands would be a
game-changer I think that's the biggest
difference between our campaign and many
of the other politicians is that we want
to empower people we trust people
whereas even some of the other more
progressive candidates on the Democratic
side still want to try and put money
into institutions and hope it gets to
people so I already know the answer to
this because we spoke to you some months
ago but for people who say okay thousand
dollar-a-month universal basic income
freedom dividend as you like to call it
where does that money come from you know
so the big trap we're in right now is
that the winners from all this new
technological innovation like artificial
intelligence and autonomous cars and
trucks and robotics are going to be the
biggest tech companies your Amazon
Google Facebook ooh BRR and right now
those companies are excellent at not
paying a lot of taxes so we need to do
is we need to put ourselves in position
benefit from all the new innovation
happening around the country then
install a value-added tax which would
help give the American public a slice of
every Amazon transaction of every Google
search and it would put us in position
to be able to pay for this freedom
dividend of $1,000 per month the
comparison I make is that right now
Alaska has a petroleum dividend of one
to two thousand dollars per Alaskan per
year funded by oil money and technology
is the oil of the 21st century so we can
make what's happening right now in
Alaska possible for all Americans so I
love this idea I've been talking about
ubi for years on this program have had
probably close to ten experts with
different ideas about how you put this
together so the policy idea I love I
went on I side with and answered
questions about my politics and the
website said David you most closely
match andrew yang that is well sure
great for but the question is to put
some context behind it
I interviewed Richard o jeddah a couple
months ago he recently announced that
even though he believes he is still a
great person to be president that he's
just not as a result of get of not
having the same name recognition and
resources he's not getting the screen
time he needs to really make a dent in
this primary he says I don't want people
to keep donating to me if I really don't
have a shot here so yeah behind you
sure I spoke to Richard just the other
day and I congratulated him on his
campaign I have to say we're in a very
very different position than Richard
where we're raising hundreds of
thousands of dollars from tens of
thousands of donors around the country
our average donation is only $19 so I
joke that our fans are even cheaper than
Bernie's but but I'm an entrepreneur and
operator and we we keep track of all of
their measurements and they're all just
going up and up and up where we're
getting much much stronger as the
campaign goes on and as every candidate
declares our traffic spikes because
people take a look at the 2020 field and
then maybe they wind up discovering me
in the campaign so we have a very very
clear path to not
just prominence and competitiveness but
we can make history here with this
campaign so it sounds like you're
agreeing that having the resources
financially is important but you're
making the case that you're building
those resources yeah I mean Richard I
feel for him because you know it's like
he doesn't come from from like a lot of
money and his mom told him anyone can be
President and he's like hey turns out
you need a lot of money a lot of
influence you know a lot of clout to run
for president in 2020 19 and he's right
and it's not an easy set of obstacles to
overcome but I'm gonna I'm an
experienced entrepreneur and operator
I've started a multi-million dollar
organization from nothing but an idea
before and this is happening in the same
way faster and so my experiences are
just have prepared me for this
in a very very different way than
Richards has for his campaign can you
talk a little bit about the decision you
made to run as a Democrat rather than as
an independent and I asked that not on
the basis of the policy positions that
you take which certainly seem to fit
very well with in the more progressive
wing of the Democratic Party but more in
the context of what we're now seeing
with Starbucks a founder Howard Schultz
sort of toying with a run as an as an
independent and we're seeing the
double-edged sword that that is in terms
of how you can have this spoiler effect
what made you decide to run as a
Democrat instead of as an independent
you know it's the same thing that that's
gotten everyone upset about Howard well
like I looked at the mechanics and said
look the Democratic Party I'm aligned
with the Democratic Party on most every
front as you saw and we need to energize
the Democratic Party with new ideas and
a new economic vision and then galvanize
the American people and wit and beat
Donald Trump like that's the whole
challenge and if you run as an
independent you run the risk of
splitting the vote and keeping Donald
Trump in office and that would be an
utter disaster so you know I'm a
friendly with Howard Schultz I don't
believe he's like you
he's intentionally doing something that
he thinks is going to help Donald Trump
stay in office but the mechanics are the
mechanics you know we have the system we
have and I will never do anything that I
think would increase the odds of Donald
Trump being president one iota because
to me he's an emblem of the accelerating
deterioration of this society so do you
think I know you said that as more
people declare on the Democratic side
that your traffic goes up as a result of
people just looking at who's out there
what are all the options that are
available to me what do you think is the
effect of a more crowded Democratic
field than a less crowded one for a
candidate like you it's actually
excellent for us because if you think
about it if there are just a few
candidates then it would be harder for
an independent minded progressive like
myself to gain traction whereas with a
more crowded field
so I'm going to run the numbers for you
and your fans because I know you guys
are like deeply engaged politically so
and this is a little bit of our take I
mean I'm here in Iowa it's my eighth
trip you Google Andrew yang Iowa you can
see the speeches I've given the hundreds
of Democratic activists here in the
state so despite the passion here in
Iowa only 5.6 percent of Iowans
participated in the Democratic caucus in
2016 a hundred seventy-one thousand
islands at a 3.1 million citizens in the
state now that numbers going to go up a
lot in 2020 might go up to something
like two hundred forty thousand but if
you have a crowded field of let's call
it fifteen to twenty candidates then in
order to finish in the top three in Iowa
you don't need 60,000 you need something
like thirty to forty thousand and so
anyone who thinks hey you know you need
gajillions of dollars in order to win
this election you you only need to get
about thirty to forty thousand Iowans on
board with your vision that's the whole
test you're going to see many candidates
crash and burn because when they come
here to Iowa their vision is not going
to resonate at all and and we're having
the opposite experience where the people
in
uwah can see what's happening there Main
streets they see what's happening in
their towns and communities and they
know the difference that $1,000 a month
would make in their own lives and the
lives of their families what's the
approach for getting into debates and I
know that this is early still and we're
not at that point yet but there's a lot
of discussion around all of these
different systems that could be put in
place to ensure that you don't have a
debate with 20 people but at the same
time you're not sort of preemptively
disqualifying people who are not as as
well known or maybe have a history in
politics like you what's the strategy
there I've got to say David like
everything is being laid out perfectly
for this campaign to make the debate
stage because Tom Perez the DNC have
already declared that they're going to
be as inclusive as possible they might
even break the debates into two nights
to accommodate a larger field and they
do not want to exclude someone so the
three criteria they have announced are a
number of supporters polling and
fundraising totals and so all we need to
do to make the debate stage is be at a
level above that of some of the other
candidates which is something we can
really achieve I mean I'm already
pulling at 1% here in Iowa I'm tied with
Kirsten Gillibrand and we all know what
Kirsten Gillibrand is going to make the
debate so we're just gonna keep on going
from here but the DNC has learned from
what happened in the last cycle they
don't want to be seen as as tilting the
scales and they've also already
announced that they're not gonna have
like a varsity and JV debate they're
gonna mix it up based upon you know just
they're gonna have everyone there in an
equal field so I'm gonna be importantly
the important thing about not wanting to
be seen as tilting the field is they're
not opposed to tilting the field as long
as they're not seen as tilting the field
so I hope that you and all of all of the
other candidates are keeping a close eye
on that you know I mean that that's very
very apt well you know it reminds me of
like the joke you tell where like if a
bear is chasing you you don't need to
outrun the bear you just need to outrun
the person next to you so all we need to
do is outdo
a campaign of someone that you know the
DNC wants to have on that stage and that
will be on that stage so I'm really
trying at this early point in the
Democratic primary to keep focused only
on issues and who is most aligned with
what the Democratic Party should be
advocating for but I want to just run by
you what is an important issue and it
will become more important later which
is that of not only electability but how
to handle a candidate like Donald Trump
who has been undoubtedly effective
between the nicknames and the rhetoric
and the onstage style at fighting in a
way that a lot of people on the Left
have not been particularly good at
punching back at how do you see that and
what do you think what would be your
approach I have had dozens maybe
hundreds of Trump voters around the
country come up to me and say I voted
for Donald Trump and I will vote for you
because you're also an outsider you want
to solve the problems you want to get
things done and you're talking about
some of the same problems that Donald
Trump elected a person in Iowa came to
me and said I cannot wait to see you
debate Donald Trump because you would
crush him and others have said the
opposite of Donald Trump is an Asian man
who likes math he's fire and bluster and
a fake entrepreneur and and I'm clear
and attached to reality and people will
see that I care about trying to solve
the problems I got Donald Trump elected
right what happens when he says little
Andrew doesn't know what he's talking
about right I mean how do you but what
what how do you deal with the the
personality aspect of it you know so our
joke around campaign headquarters is
that his nickname for me will be comrade
yang which has big racial connotations
but that the American people I'll tell
you when I go out to to the folks in
Iowa New Hampshire and also across the
country I was just in in Minnesota last
night the fact that I'm talking about
the problems I got Donald Trump elected
I guess people focused on me in a
different way where the the great
mistake of the Democrats in the last
cycle here's the truth the reason why
Donald Trump won in 2016 is that we
automated away four million
manufacturing jobs
in Michigan Ohio Pennsylvania Wisconsin
Missouri Iowa all swing states that they
needed to win and did win and the
Democratic Party instead of saying yeah
that's true and we need to dramatically
reshape our economy to work for
different people instead just dismiss
the concerns of those people and we're
like well you know like that you know
does not not in step with the times you
know just the fact that I'm talking
about the problems on the ground in
people's lives
it was a very very long way with a lot
of Trump voters a lot of independents
and we don't need all of them we just
need to keep the democrats and
progressives aligned with our vision for
what we can do in this country and then
peel off 5 10 15 20 % of Trump voters
but I'm very confident that I if I'm the
nominee I will I will beat Donald Trump
heads down hands down this is a very
very shaping up to be a very very
interesting Democratic primary and we've
been speaking with Andrew yang who is
running indeed as a Democrat for
president in 2020 Andrew continued a
good luck on the campaign trail we're
going to be following it and I really
appreciate you talking to me today
thank you David anyone who wants to
check out our policies we're up to
something like 80 policy proposals we're
not just universal basic income just go
to yang 2020 calm or Google Andrew yang
but you'll see that we have a real
vision for the country that Americans
are getting very excited about